no one is invincible not even Earth's
Mightiest Heroes don't believe us well
consider the following evidence as we
look at the biggest weaknesses of every
member of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
versions of the Avengers saying that
someone's strength can also be their
weakness is cliche but it's cliche
because it's true an Iron Man is a
perfect example while Tony Stark's mini
arc reactor has been the source of a
number of close calls
it's his need to shoulder the burden
that's been his biggest weakness when
the Battle of New York happened in
2012's the Avengers everything changed
for Tony the knowledge that hostile
alien forces were waiting out in the
void was too much for him to process
without doing something about it
stark you know that's a one-way trip
save the rest for the turn Jay
well this sense of responsibility helps
save the world multiple times it also
feeds Starks biggest failures it
justifies in his mind his deception in
Avengers age of Ultron and leads to the
creation of a sentient robot that almost
destroys the world it's also a big part
of his motivation to back the sokovia
accords and Captain America Civil War
sending him on a collision course with
Steve Rogers and leaving the world
divided it's true that we tend to expect
from the world what we expect from
ourselves so if you're a selfless and
courageous patriot who always demands
the best from yourself then you're
probably going to expect the best from
everyone around you I'm not gonna fight
you
you're my friend and if you're Steve
Rogers you'll be disappointed a lot it's
this aspect of Steve that helps start so
much trouble and Captain America Civil
War of course he doesn't see it need for
the sokovia accords he expects the best
from everyone around him it's why the
deceptions he endures from Black Widow
and Nick Fury who he knows our spies
somehow come as a surprise to him and
it's why he's able to join shield
without noticing the growing threat of
Hydra until fury is nearly dying on his
living room floor ever since his first
big screen appearance in 2011's Thor the
God of Thunder struggles with the fact
that he just isn't used to being the
loser
the problem with almost always being the
most powerful guy in the room is that
you might not know what to do once that
power can't save you that's true for
Thor as soon as we meet him in his first
solo film he eventually finds the
humility to win back Mjolnir and regain
his powers but when he's first made
mortal all he knows to do is to try to
recapture the hammer of course there's
also his transformation into the so
called growth or an Avengers endgame
although Thor isn't alone in his failure
to stop Thanos from killing half the
universe and Avengers infinity war he
lets the weight of everything fall
directly on his shoulders it's what
drives him to kill Thanos and the fall
as low as we've ever seen him one thing
that's always been clear about the Hulk
is that his biggest weakness at least in
terms of working with the team is that
you're never really sure exactly which
Hulk you're going to be dealing with if
you get the wrong one he's just as
likely to smash his teammates as he is
to smash the real enemy
[Applause]
while Loki is doubtlessly using outside
power to influence the Hulk when he goes
wild on the Helicarrier and the Avengers
the Hulk isn't someone you have to work
that hard to manipulate well the moment
is arguably one of the most hilarious of
the film and the Hulk shows his
willingness to lash out at allies when
he sucker punches Thor in Grand Central
Station he's one of the four Avengers
who are assaulted by scarlet witch's
mental powers in Avengers age of Ultron
yet he's the only one who goes on a
rampage through Johannesburg and in thor
ragnarok there are no witches or
warlocks playing with his mind when he
chooses to attack Thor in sukar's arena
basically the other guy is unpredictable
as we've seen from Black Widow time and
time again as much as she fights and
sacrifices to redeem herself the
powerful part of her is convinced she's
not worth saving
it's what Loki tries to exploit in The
Avengers and it's one of the things that
kills her and Avengers end game after
Loki's plot to manipulate her and the
Avengers is revealed black widow
continues to be shaken by the experience
you notice her to be unmade you know
that I do and in spite of her selfless
aerobics in later installments in
Avengers age of Ultron she implies that
she's as much of a monster as the Hulk
and calls the notion of her being an
Avenger a dream while you can hardly
call her sacrifice an in-game a weakness
it seems likely this viewing of herself
as a monster is part of what convinces
her she should be the one to die on
Boromir rather than Hawkeye Hawkeye is
one of the few Avengers whose greatest
weakness is more on the physical side of
things as he's limited by his ammo
without his arrows Clint is far from
helpless in most of his appearances
we've seen him the equal of many of his
fellow Avengers when it comes to
hand-to-hand combat but when it comes to
the threats that live in the world of
the super he needs those weapons and
when he runs out he's in a lot of
trouble in civil war he would have been
useless without his arrows and even with
them he was no match for vision that's
probably why in Avengers age of Ultron
we learn he's come up with some creative
means to extend his ammo when Scarlet
Witch joins the battle against Ultron's
drones in sokovia that's when we learn
her biggest weakness a lack of
confidence
you can hardly blame her for her fear
though not that long ago she was on
Ultron side and she's still pretty new
to the superhero business it takes a pep
talk from Hawkeye to get her back on her
feet if you go out there you fight and
you fight to kill staying here you're
good I'll send your brother come find
you but if you step out that door you
are an Avenger but it happens again and
Captain America Civil War when Hawkeye
shows up to free Wanda from the Avengers
compound at first it seems like she'd
rather stay and she believes she's
dangerous enough to warrant the house
arrest Tony Stark has her under once
more Clint has to make her face some
hard truths before she takes action
since the death of vision and infinity
war and her one-sided showdown with
Thanos and in Game one his lack of
confidence may be less of an issue we'll
have to wait and see
unfortunately Quicksilver didn't live
long enough to get an extended look at
what he would have been like as an
Avenger but during his time an age of
Ultron it's clear the speedster was
usually governed by one thing his rage
its Pietro's anger at Tony Stark that
pits him against the Avengers and it's
eventually what puts him in Ultron's
camp we've seen that fury start to boil
up a couple of times first against
Captain America and then against Hawkeye
when the Archer incapacitates Wanda in
the comics quicksilver's anger leads him
to actually betray the Avengers a number
of times we'll never know if the same
would have been true in the films he's
seemed to have mellowed out at least a
little considering both his sacrifice to
save Hawkeye and a young sokovia boy and
his willingness to take a little
friendly fire in the arm from ASA Kofi
and cop without punching him in the
throat for it tony stark says vision
might become the most powerful of the
Avengers before the Android comes to
life an age of Ultron envisions entrance
into the airport battle in Berlin
certainly makes him seem like the most
powerful hero there but in the end the
mind stone that was the key to bringing
him to life proves his undoing in more
ways than one maybe I am a monster
I don't think I'd know if I were one
first there's the obvious way when
Thanos rips the gem from the androids
had an infinity war it kills vision
instantly since he isn't one of the
victims of panasas fateful snap his
death isn't reversed in endgame but we
see some other ways visions reliance on
the mine stone makes him vulnerable
earlier in civil war the fact that
Wanda's powers come from the mine stone
is what allows her to overpower vision
when Hawkeye comes to rescue her from
house arrest later is over reliance on
the stone plus his worry for Wanda's
injuries forced him to miss his target
and blast war machine nearly killing him
while James Rhodes years in the war
machine suit have made him an
accomplished Avenger there is at least
one way in which he'll never be Iron
Man's equal he may have a similar suit
but he doesn't have the mine that
created them Rhodey skills are nothing
to sneeze at even without the suit as we
see an Iron Man 3 his cunning courage
and marksmanship helped him survive
fights with multiple extremists fueled
bad guys the problem is that when he's
in the suit and the suit fails him he
doesn't have the technical know-how to
compensate take his fall in Civil War
Tony Stark finds himself in a similar
situation an iron man when his pushed
towards the upper atmosphere freezes his
suit and causes it to temporarily lose
power because Tony is an engineer and he
knows what the suit can do he's able to
get the armor working again before he's
a skid mark Rhodes doesn't have the same
capacity when vision accidentally blasts
him in Civil War and he falls his fate
is sealed ever since he was introduced
in Captain America the Winter Soldier
Falcon has proven himself to be a fierce
fighter in Civil War he goes toe-to-toe
with several Avengers and he makes short
work of crossbones mercenaries in an
endgame he takes down alien monsters
twice his size but without his wings
Sam Wilson is still an accomplished
professional soldier whether he can take
to the sky or not but from what we've
seen of him so far his hand-to-hand
skills need some work he isn't much help
against the Winter Soldier without his
wings and in his clash with Brock rumlow
the villains as it best you're out of
your depth
while he could probably knock your
average person on there but without his
wings he can barely keep up in some ways
when Tony Stark barged into Peter
Parker's life in civil war it was a gift
in other ways it's been a burden while
stark helps to enable Peter to become
the best hero he can be he also imposes
a large shadow over spider-man's life
that the younger hero constantly feels
pressured to live up to what is he your
ward no I'm Peter by the way dr. strange
all your made-up names um I'm spider-man
then he wants to do nothing but impress
his mentor and prove his worthiness as
an Avenger after iron man's death Peter
feels the responsibility to fill the
void Tony left behind it's this drive to
live up to the legend of Iron Man that
leads him to make some questionable
decisions it pushes him to do a lot more
than web them up and keep his distance
like Tony tells him to and Civil War it
gets him in a number of fights that
don't end well in homecoming and it
drives him to intervene in the arm sail
that leads to the Staten Island Ferry
being blasted in half and him far from
home his feelings of inadequacy make him
an easy target for Quentin Beck's
manipulations imagine the level of
distrust you must have toward yourself
to not only insist you be stored in cryo
freeze but to agree that your caretaker
will be the guy who until a few days ago
blamed you for his father's death that's
the situation in which Bucky finds
himself in the mid credits scene of
Civil War
sure about this I can't trust my own
mind
Bucky doesn't trust himself and with
good reason in spite of being free of
hydras control and living incognito for
two years a man he's never met is able
to find the code that unlocks the
assassin living in his brain and
unleashes him on innocence we don't even
know if she really one else in Wakanda
was able to cure Bucky of his Hydra
conditioning as it hasn't been mentioned
since civil war we've mostly only seen
Bucky as part of battles with huge
opposing armies what's going to happen
when he has to deal with the smaller
scale domestic situation is he going to
be able to trust himself knowing the
damage he's capable of
Scott Lang has a massive inferiority
complex when it comes to other more
experienced superheroes we see it as
early as his fistfight with Falcon what
we do see if I'm in civil war makes it
clear that he's utterly starstruck by
Captain America Captain America mr. Lang
it's an honor I'm shaking your hand too
long
ah this is awesome Captain America but
his feelings of inferiority are most
clear in endgame
we're his team mates enjoy picking on
him because of it and even though
everyone else seems to be embarrassed to
even be in the same room as the
diminished bro Thor when the Thunder God
talks Scott grins and nods like a little
kid listening to his favorite baseball
player tell a story what's so sad about
it is how often Scott proves himself to
be equal to his teammates he kicks
Falcons butt and ant-man does some
serious damage in civil war and he's one
of the most pivotal heroes an end game
regardless of how the other Avengers
talk to him
he's the one who comes up with the idea
of using the quantum realm to travel
through time he saves a number of
Avengers from drowning when Thanos
attacks he takes out a Chitauri
Leviathan by punching it in the face and
he kills call obsidian by stepping on
him so come on Avengers give this guy a
break
caring about your family should hardly
be seen as a weakness but the sad truth
is when you want Black Panther to make
mistakes the clear route seems to be to
attack his family
the first mistake we see to chaol up
Mayock is when he dedicates himself to
killing Bucky and Civil War the reason
of course is because he incorrectly
believes Bucky planted the bomb that
killed his father
T'Challa fails in his quest for revenge
but it's not for lack of trying so I ask
you it's both warrior
and King how long do you think you can
keep our friend safe from me in black
panther kill mongers initial victory
over to Chawla at warrior Falls is only
possible because of the very notion of
family the revelation that T'Challa
father killed his own brother and
abandoned the young kill monger in
America leads black panther to make the
bad choice of accepting kill mongers
challenge which ends with an epic
beatdown some may argue the point
the sorcerer himself would probably take
issue with it but Stephen strange is
penchant for keeping his own counsel is
something that's bound to betray him one
of these days
strange makes a lot of pivotal decisions
that seem and explicable to his allies
and more often than not he does it
without bothering to explain himself in
Doctor Strange Mordo and Wong both think
he's abandoned them when he actually has
a plan to trick Dormammu in infinity war
he surrenders the time stone to Thanos
without letting anyone else in on the
reason why there was no other way
of course in those instances things
ultimately worked out although not
without cost the Avengers were left
dumbfounded for years about his decision
on Titan and things haven't always
worked out like when he transported
everyone into the mirror dimension and
Doctor Strange where he made things
worse
he and Mordo eventually escaped but
ultimately it leads to the death of the
ancient one we haven't seen Captain
Marvel's confidence backfire on her yet
but it's a good bet were bound to in the
beginning of endgame Carol Danvers is
convinced that the only reason the
Avengers weren't able to defeat Thanos
is because she wasn't with them her
comments rubbed the group the wrong way
but she doesn't back down it seems
likely that confidence in part is what
helps keep her a loner perhaps one of
the biggest differences between the
Carol Danvers of the comics and the
screen is that so far the Captain Marvel
of the MCU doesn't seem like much of a
team player
when she returns to earth at the end of
the movie she gets some more fuel for
her confidence Danis is strongest blow
barely phases her and he's only able to
throw her aside because of the Infinity
stones from what we've seen of her
interacting with other heroes she
doesn't seem to like asking for help
eventually that's going to get her into
trouble rocket has some fairly
significant character flaws he's rude he
pushes people away and he's got an ego
the size of egos planet but at the end
of the day Rockets biggest weakness is
simply that he's small rocket can be a
terrible opponent he takes on almost all
of yondu's Ravagers and guardians of the
galaxy - by himself he's a terror with a
gun in his hand and given the right
tools and materials he can make you a
high-tech super weapon faster than you
can say MacGyver but catch him without a
gun a high tech gadget or at the
controls of a spaceship he's helpless
when he attacks Ronan at the end of
guardians of the galaxy the Kree barely
has to even move to knock rocket in the
next week he's almost completely useless
against Gamora early in the movie when
they're fighting over quill
we wouldn't want to make him mad if
there's so much as a butter knife nearby
but Marvel's favorite trash Bandar is in
the end the size of a build-a-bear and
it can be a huge disadvantage honestly
it does exact second I thought you were
built
maybe I am shortly after endgame opens
we find nebula playing paper football
with tony stark on board the Benatar
when she shakes Tony's hand after her
victory this is about the most cordial
and social we've seen er she also
practically looks like a starving dog
trying to decide whether or not a
concerned human handing her food was
trustworthy like Gamora nebula has spent
most of her adult life as an assassin
under Thanos his thumb now that she's
free of him she's going to find herself
in something of a new life and a lot of
it will be challenging when quill
comments on how bad nebula is lying in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 it's more
than a joke of course she's bad at lying
she spent her whole life outside
anything approaching a normal social
situation assuming nebula is planning on
becoming a regular member of the
Guardians she'll likely find it
difficult to figure out how or who to be
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]